Als ich rausging und meine Kurse unterrichtete, waren Biosensoren das Wichtigste, womit die Leute zu kämpfen hatten.
Sie verstanden nicht, wie irgendjemand einen Biosensor in sich haben konnte.
Sie denken, dass sie injiziert werden müssen.
Sie denken, dass sie mit einem RFID-Tag versehen werden müssen.
Sie denken, dass sie sich für eine Injektion wie einen Impfstoff oder was auch immer anmelden müssen.
Nichts davon ist wahr.
Dann sagen die nächsten Leute, naja, dann brauchen sie einen Turm und.
Und dann die nächste Gruppe von Leuten.
Nun, nein, sie müssen ein Wearable haben und all das.
Warum glaubst du das alles?
Es gibt einen grundlegenden Grund dafür, dass das Gehirn eines jeden zuerst dorthin geht, egal wer Sie sind.
Du sagst, was?
Nein, du müsstest ein RFID in mich einbauen oder du müsstest dies, das und alles andere tun.
Die Biosensoren bestehen aus Ihren roten Blutkörperchen, Ihren Peptiden, Ihren Aminoketten, Ihrer DNA.
Wie ist das möglich?
Ist dein Körper elektrisch?
Ja oder nein?
Ja, aber es ist nur mein Herz.
Was ist mit deinem Gehirn?
Nun, okay, gut.
Aber niemand kann es sehen.
Da sind wir wieder.
Ist dein Körper elektrisch?
Ja, aber nur mein Herz und mein Gehirn.
Nein.
Wie hebt Mama das Auto ab?
Das Kleinkind und ihre Arme reißen ihr nicht vom Körper ab.
Wie passiert das?
Da sind wir wieder.
Ist der Körper elektrisch?
Also habe ich versucht, den Leuten hier zwei Dinge ganz klar beizubringen.
Nummer eins, Gott ist real.
Nummer zwei, du hast ein Körperteil.
Sie haben dich 150 von 6000 Jahren nicht darüber sprechen lassen, dass dieser Körperteil hier ist.
Es war schon immer ein Teil der Menschen.
Wo ist es hingegangen?
Das erfordert Nachdenken.
Das erfordert Analyse, nicht Hinschauen.
Ich einfach.
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Du bist erwachsen.
Du.
Wer auch immer Sie sind, es ist Ihre Aufgabe, es zu verstehen.
Es ist nicht meine Aufgabe, dich zu versohlen.
Aber sie sind deine Unwissenheit.
Ihr Mangel an Lust oder Willen zu verstehen bedeutet Tod.
Weil das Kriegsführung ist, elektronische Kriegsführung.
Das ist nicht.
Wir werden reinkommen und Kumbaya singen.
Wir werden meditieren.
Wir werden einfach etwas über unsere Fraktale lernen.
Ich bin ein Schamane.
Ich mag Energiearbeit.
Ich werde heilen.
Das ist elektronische Kriegsführung.
Und das ist der Grund, warum ich keine Freunde finde, weil ich diesen Blödsinn mit allen nicht vermisse, so wie sie es all die Jahre gewohnt sind.
Nun, ich verstehe es nicht.
Es ist Bewusstsein.
Es ist.
Weißt du wen?
Und jeder liebt dich.
Klick, Klick.
Oh, was ist passiert?
Oh, ich weiß nicht.
Ich bin einfach zu dämlich.
Ich sollte Sandwiches haben.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ist der Körper elektrisch, alter Mann?
Ich bin neulich ins Krankenhaus gegangen, nachdem ich fast diesen Mistkerl einen Herzinfarkt erlitten hatte.
Er kam mit Polstern auf mich zugerannt.
Versuchte, mir einen Stromschlag zu verpassen, so wie es die Cops tun, wenn sie auf die Taser schießen.
Sie haben es weggenommen, um es von innen heraus zu überwachen, und sie haben es.
Oder die Dokumente, die ich lese.
Du wärst nicht da.
Was auf Maui passiert ist, wäre nicht einfach passiert.
Oh, da sind wir wieder.
Nein, ich bleibe jetzt drin und das bedeutet, dass mein Kopf zu dick ist.
Das kann nicht sein.
Ich nicht.
Hör auf, deine Wut, deine Ablehnung und deine Unfähigkeit, über andere Menschen zu lesen, zu zitieren.
Weil ich hier nicht nur für mich selbst spreche.
Offensichtlich habe ich mich da draußen aufgehalten.
Aber das Wichtigste, auf das wir alle stoßen, sind Freunde, Mamas Schulden, was auch immer es sein mag.
Kannst du lesen?
Es ist so einfach wie ein College-Lehrbuch.
Wir beschäftigen uns seit anderthalb Jahren damit.
Die Leute würden es lieber leugnen.
Kannst du mir jetzt sagen, warum das so ist?
Die Frage an den Kommentator: Nochmals, nicht auf Leuten herumhacken.
Ich spreche die Stimmung des Kommentars an.
Wie könnte eine Handvoll Menschen die gesamte Biologie der ganzen Welt kontrollieren?
Wie könnten wir alle Hurrikane und das ganze Wetter beobachten und bis 2025 die volle Wetterkontrolle für die Library of Congress haben?
Woher wissen wir mit dem Energieministerium, wo die nuklearen Folgen weltweit liegen?
Woher wissen wir, wo sich alle Bodenschichten in Bezug auf die gesamte Landwirtschaft befinden, die wir mit intelligenten Saatgutinitiativen betreiben?
Und was haben wir mit all den ursprünglichen Samen gemacht, bevor wir auf GMO umgestiegen sind?
Oh.
Wer war die meiste Zeit Ihres Lebens für Ihre Gesundheit verantwortlich.
Du bist deine Familie, oder?
Denn wenn Sie nicht fünf Therapeuten, sechs Ärzte haben und Sie vier- oder fünfmal im Jahr Ärzte aufsuchen, stimmt etwas nicht mit Ihnen.
Okay, wir leben alle so.
Das ist großartig.
Aber ich habe dort einen Kommentar abgegeben.
Ich sagte: Hey, nur weil es immer so gemacht wurde, heißt das, dass es richtig ist, besonders angesichts der Tatsache, dass sich die Umgebung verändert hat?
Könnte es vor vier Jahren gewesen sein?
Warum gibt es keinen Widerstand?
Richtig.
Karen Kingston ging dorthin, um Sheriffs zu verklagen und ihnen zu sagen, dass sie die neuen COVID-Impfungen nicht gleich hier verteilen sollen.
Und ich sagte, das sei dämlich.
Aber hier kommt, weil sie das System nicht versteht, wie das Targeted gegen Garland.
Aber hier kommt jetzt, genau jetzt auf YouTube.
Fox News.
Halten Sie sich nicht daran.
Okay.
Du hast den Leuten, keinem von euch da draußen, Patriotenkram erzählt, was auch immer.
Du hast nicht gesagt, dass du gelogen hast.
Und ich will es nicht hören.
Ich kenne mich zwischen dem Mediendoktor und all diesen Leuten verdammt gut aus.
Breites Body Area Network, da ist der Liefervektor.
Das ist der Grund, warum unsere Kinder davon lernen müssen.
Der Marktanteil weiß alles darüber.
Wir werden den ganzen Tag hier sein, weil du verdammt noch mal nicht zugeben wirst, wie diese Systeme funktionieren.
Sie möchten Ihre Fernbedienungen nicht abgeben.
Nun, die Person, die mir diese Frage gestellt hat, sollten Sie sich jetzt stellen, wenn sie schon immer gewusst hat, was die Technik, die Hardware und die Software für die Reichweite erfordern.
Um deine Frage zu beantworten, wie sie das wirklich machen, was ich auch technisch gemacht habe.
Aber als Nächstes sollte kritisches Denken sein, naja, das sind eine Menge Leute, die all diese Systeme verwalten müssen.
Aber ich weiß, nicht wahr?
Wissen Sie, wie viele junge Menschen diese Jobs annehmen?
Ihr Kommentator sollte sich dieses Video zur Rekrutierung eines Sensorjägers von vor vier Jahren ansehen und Sie sollten Google und YouTube, Google Biosensors und dann synthetische Telepathie wählen.
Dann Dr.
Cody, der bei Walter Reed mit Tech for Psych.
Dann wirst du vielleicht anfangen, das für alle anderen zu verstehen.
Biophysik, Biohacking, Biomedizintechnik, drahtlose Gewebetechnik, drahtlose Arzneimittelherstellung.
Das machen sie am Wochenende.
Biohacking, bei dem Python und Pi vor acht Jahren ihr Garagentor mit ihrem Verstand öffneten und ihre Kaffeekanne mit ihrem Verstand starteten.
Wie kontrollieren sie möglicherweise die Biologie?
Nun, sie haben eine Menge Leute eingestellt, die keine Angst haben, es zu lesen.
Das ist etwas, wenn wir keine Angst haben zu lesen, wenn wir innehalten und zurücktreten und sagen: Hey, was ist das?
Ich will es wissen.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Du musst es nicht wissen.
Das ist auch für jemand anderen.
Nein, nein, das wirkt sich auf meinen Körper aus.
Ich will nur wissen, wie es funktioniert?
Und wenn die Leute sauer auf dich werden, weil sie wissen wollen, wie es funktioniert, ist das der erste Schritt, rote Flagge.
Whoa, whoa.
Alles, was ich getan habe, ist den Leuten zu zeigen, wie es funktioniert.
Merkt ihr, wie hoch der Widerstand immer ist?
Oh, das ist unmöglich.
Mein Kopf ist zu dick.
Ich verstehe nicht.
Wie konnte es aus mir gemacht werden?
Weil dein Körper elektrisch ist und sie dich über die menschliche Anatomie belogen haben.
6000 Jahre menschliche Anatomie haben sich beim Krabbeln nicht verändert und Blavatsky sagte: Oh ja, nichts existiert außer dem, was man sehen kann.
Sie haben es an einer privaten Universität versteckt.
Private Universität.
Zahlen Sie fürs Spielen.
Sie wollen Zugang haben, um Menschen drahtlos zu kontrollieren, so wie es die Reihen der Christen seit Jahren mit den Nanolipiden tun.
Ich gebe dir ein System zum Einloggen und einen Job zu erledigen.
Für dich wird es keinen Gesetzesbruch geben.
Tu niemals, was du willst, oder lass es immer verschwinden.
Warum?
Weil die Leute es lieber leugnen und ihre Freunde behalten und Konflikte vermeiden wollen, als ernsthaft zu sagen: Hey, ich glaube, du hast ein Körperteil gestohlen.
Du hast keine neue Technologie bekommen.
Und das ist die andere Komponente.
Woher kam diese Technologie?
Woher kommen all die Tests für diese Biosensoren?
Scarpa.
Sag mir wie.
Das gleiche Problem.
Es tut uns leid.
Du erfährst nicht, wie es funktioniert.
Und das ist der Grund, warum letztes Halloween 107 Justicia gewählt hat.
David Nino.
Mikey Adams.
Was haben sie dir gesagt?
Hexerei.
Sie sagten, fürchtet euch vor den Hexen.
Und ich sagte, du solltest besser Angst davor haben, dass dieser Mistkerl mit einem heruntergefallenen Handy hinter dir im Supermarkt herläuft, was wir auf Videos zu sehen begannen.
Also bist du bereit zuzugeben, dass sich dein Körper nicht verändert hat?
Nichts hat sich geändert.
Außer du hast herausgefunden, dass sie gelogen haben.
Okay, das ist nicht meine Schuld.
Und das ist nicht die Schuld dessen, der dich auf diesen Kanal geschickt hat.
Das ist deine Schuld.
Weil es bequemer war, zu leugnen, war es einfacher, nicht damit umzugehen.
Bis die Drohne vorbei ist, leitet dein Zuhause ein Ebola-Signal durch deinen Körper.
Jetzt sind plötzlich alle auf meinem Kanal eins und Verdammt noch mal.
Warte eine Minute.
Das ist ein Oh, mein Gott.
Das ist das Liefersystem.
Ja, das habe ich auch gesagt.
Ich sagte, wo ist die Telemetrie für das menschliche Kreislaufsystem?
Wo ist es hingegangen?
Wenn es ein Impfstoff ist, ist es kein Impfstoff.
Wenn es Graphen benötigt.
Graphen wird mit Nanotechnologie für Daten und Bandbreite durch Haut und Gewebe verwendet.
Metamaterialien.
Was machst du?
Warum fragst du 2013 nicht Professor Ian?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich würde es lieber leugnen.
Meine Freunde reden nicht gern darüber.
Meine Freunde wären lieber hier drüben und würden über die Bibel reden, über alles, was die Politik hier übertrumpft, und über den endlosen Quatsch, der dich nirgendwohin bringt.
Ja, lass uns noch ein bisschen darüber reden.
Auf diese Weise dreht man sich im Kreis.
Dafür habe ich noch ein Schild.
Das ist die Cue-Bewegung.
Sie schützen die Banker.
Gehe zu Wikipedia.
Oh nein, es ist ein großes militärisches Zeichen.
Wir werden in letzter Minute reinkommen, alle Bösewichte töten und wir werden die Macht übernehmen, Trump ins Amt bringen.
Und ich habe heute Morgen gefragt, also wenn du das alles gemacht hast, glaube ich nicht, dass ich es gepostet habe.
Sobald du das alles gemacht hast.
NUNBERG Das ist nicht beim ersten Mal passiert.
Also wirst du es jetzt ein zweites Mal machen.
Das erste Mal wurde daraus das Manhattan-Projekt.
Jobs im Projekt Paperclip.
Jep.
Und was sonst?
Südamerika zum live gehen da unten und super.
Also ist es nicht passiert.
Jetzt sagst du allen, dass ich es wieder tun werde.
Das ist richtig.
Du wirst verdammt noch mal nichts tun, um zu unterbrechen.
Erklärung zur Pentagon-Richtlinie 3.000.09 Tödliche autonome Waffen.
Stimmt, das bist du nicht.
Und das war das Jahr 2017.
Es ist das physische Cyber-Rückgrat der Polizei, das nicht nur all die Biosensoren benötigt, die Sie nicht aus Ihnen herausholen können, weil sie aus Ihrer DNA und Ihrem Gewebe bestehen, sondern auch Ihre DNA.
Das Signal zu verbreiten, von dem du nicht einmal weißt, dass es da drin ist, weil es dir dein ganzes Leben lang gesagt wurde.
Die Schockreserve, bevor wir zum Biofeld übergehen, ist für Stimmungsringe und wer weiß verdammt noch mal, dass sie nicht existiert?
Nun, dein Bruder ist zur Arbeit gegangen und hat deine DNA katalogisiert und dich hinter Mauern und Gang-Stalking verarscht, woran du wahrscheinlich auch nicht glaubst.
Das ist okay.
Du nennst es das falsche Wort.
Es heißt Signature Reduction Force.
Google-Finger.
Leg das für einen verdammten Job in Holz und sieh zu, wie sie fließen.
Gutes Geld.
Ja.
Das sind die Typen in den weißen Vans.
Wie der Finders-Kult.
Oh, sie wurden verhaftet.
Nein, haben sie nicht.
Du solltest wahrscheinlich auch darüber lesen.
Und dann ist hier der.
Oh, wir haben einen großen Film.
Wir werden etwas tun.
Du machst nichts.
Wir haben Organhandel im Gange.
Wir haben Probleme mit diesen elektronischen Kriegssystemen, die nicht nur dazu dienen, einige Flugzeuge zu entführen, sondern auch zivile Ziele zu erreichen.
Siehst du, diese Diskussionen wären hilfreich gewesen.
Aber du hast Menschen getötet.
Ja.
Wo ist Assange?
Das war seine Diskussion.
Edward Snowden dagegen war das seine Diskussion.
Auch hier habe ich mit der Hardware gearbeitet, die alle überwachte.
Es war meine Aufgabe, diese Prismenbox auf dem OC3 und dem O C 24 auf AT&T in Chicago anzubringen.
Und die Daten von allen, es ist diese Box, klar und sauber für den Backend der Meinungsverschiedenheiten.
Nun, ich weiß es zu schätzen, dass Sie vielleicht keinen solchen Job hatten, also haben Sie Snowden gesehen und gewartet.
Nein, nein, nein.
Der Typ ist voller Mist.
Er gefährdet alle, indem er über die Geheimnisse der NSA spricht.
Also, wie viele Jahre ist das her?
Zehn.
Richtig.
Okay, jetzt sind wir hier.
COVID hat ein eigenes Rechenzentrum.
COVID ist eine Band.
Oh, ja.
Deshalb habe ich Ihnen heute das Backend gezeigt, warum COVID ihr eigenes Wide Body Area Network für das Internet der Dinge hat.
Das ist da.
Genau da.
Ich habe es heute gezeigt.
Das ist dein Grund dafür.
Also, was wirst du dagegen tun?
Verdächtige Beobachter.
Jeder scheint großen Respekt vor diesem Typen zu haben, was die Recherche angeht, Nassau herauszufordern und all das.
In einem seiner letzten Videos sagte er, die letzte Verteidigungslinie ist Ihr Biofeld, ihr elektrischer Körperteil.
Nun, verdammt noch mal, weil es von der menschlichen Resonanz und allem elektrischen, was passiert, beeinflusst wird, außer den Menschen, die es weiterhin leugnen.
Warum?
Warum leugnen?
Sie haben es gestohlen.
Sie haben es versteckt.
Es ist keine neue Technologie.
Sie stahlen den Körperteil, verbanden ihn mit der Cloud und verteilten Fernbedienungen an Kartelle, Drogenhändler, ihre Freunde und Mitarbeiter des Außenministeriums.
Und wenn diese Leute wollten, dass eine Freundin oder ein Freund oder Leute in einem Rechtsstreit die Klappe halten, ist Schluss.
Oh, es ist einfach zu schwer.
Nun, so funktioniert es.
Dann zerre ich dir immer wieder den Hintern, wer auch immer du sein magst, das ist dein Kopf gegen die Ablehnung.
Und ich denke, ich glaube an Biomedizin, WLAN, Gewebetechnik.
Es ist genau da, es ist quasi hier.
Und wir sind immer wieder auf diesem Kanal, egal wie viele Dokumente Sie veröffentlichen, egal was Sie sagen, die Menschen um uns herum, in unseren eigenen Familien.
Oh, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Und da haben wir alle die richtige Bedeutung von n d a I have a job gelernt.
Darüber darf ich nicht sprechen.
Oh.
Es ist elektronische Kriegsführung, das Zivilisten ins Visier nehmen.
Es war so wichtig, den Körperteil und das gesamte Wissen über die menschliche Anatomie und die Materialphysik, die wir verwenden, zu verbergen.
Einstein muss rausgehen und über die Schwerkraft lügen.
Jeder in der Welt der Physik weiß, dass an dem, was sie sagen, etwas verdammt falsch ist, was unseren Umgang mit Hochenergie-Teilchenphysik angeht.
Hast du getan, wer auch immer du bist.
Haben Sie die Aufzählung in diesem Dokument zur Überwachung und Überwachung von Krankheiten bemerkt?
Hochenergie-Teilchenphysik.
Das ist richtig.
Wie letztes Jahr an Halloween.
Oh, es ist, als gäbe es ein Wettrüsten um diese Gleichungen bioelektromagnetischer DNA-Algorithmen.
Das ist richtig.
Wenn wir also die Realität ignorieren, lügen wir über die menschliche Anatomie.
Wir lügen jeden Tag darüber, was wir für einen Job tun.
Was passiert, wenn Jahre vergehen, bis endlich jemand auftaucht und sagt: Du lügst.
Wir mögen sie nicht.
Wir wollen keinen Konflikt.
Oh, willkommen in den letzten vier Jahren, in denen wir zugesehen haben, wie die Q-Bewegung alles niedergebrannt hat, weil der Kontrollabschwung angeordnet wurde.
Hier sind wir.
Und sie machen es immer noch.
Deshalb sage ich meinem Kanal, dass die Leute, die mir wichtig sind, sich nicht auf diesen politischen Blödsinn einlassen.
Beobachten.
Der Film wird sich in schreckliche Dinge verwandeln und mal sehen, das tut er nicht.
Was?
Ich würde mich gerne irren, aber du hast es seit 6000 Jahren nicht geschafft, ihren Kalender zu brechen.
Ich habe ein Buch von Michael Syrian.
Verpiss dich.
Siehst du, plötzlich ist hier das Große Erwachen.
Okay, wo ist der Körperteil?
Willst du einen kleineren?
Woher haben Sie Ihre Technologie für nichtinvasive und für zwei von drei?
Denn denken Sie daran, es gab keine satanische Panik.
Ja.
Also, wo ist der Körperteil?
Derjenige, den du treffen wirst.
Denn wo ist die Telemetrie für elektronische Kriegsführung?
Alles passiert gerade auf Befehl und Kontrolle im Militär.
Wo ist es?
Ja, da haben wir's.
Ich sagte unsichtbarer Körperteil, von dem du dachtest, du müsstest ihn nicht kennen.
Darüber musstest du dir keine Sorgen machen.
Es ist Fufu.
Es ist cool.
Wen kümmert das?
Ja.
Jetzt geht es um Leben und Tod.
Gute Arbeit, sich über Leute lustig zu machen, oder?
Findest du es auch klug, etwas zu leugnen?
Verstehst du jetzt?
Jeder von euch.
Warum bin ich, ähm.
Warum bewegt sich meine Flugbahn?
Weil ich versuche, sehr konzentriert und standhaft zu bleiben.
Du hast einen Deal.
Okay.
Es ist echt.
Also haben wir einen Deal.
Aber die Leute machen das.
Sie sagen, nein, das kann es nicht.
Oh mein Gott.
Darauf haben Hoover und Dulles und sie alle gezählt.
Sie zählen jetzt immer noch darauf.
Und merkst du, dass sie es tun?
Ich bin lieber ein Patriot mit meinen mageren Freunden, als das Widebody-Netzwerk zuzugeben.
Finde heraus, wie du damit umgehen kannst.
Beschäftige dich damit.
Und dann jage ich Leute, von denen ich weiß, dass sie gefährlich sind, weil sie immer noch darüber lügen.
Was bedeutet, dass irgendwo jemand einen Knopf hat.
Ja, ich weiß.
Es ist viel einfacher, sich einfach wohl zu fühlen.
Okay, nun, diejenigen von uns hier auf dem Kanal, wir werden uns euch nicht anschließen, weil wir wissen, dass Bequemlichkeit der Tod ist, wenn man nach einer Weile miteinander auskommt, man es gewohnt ist.
Lass uns einfach.
Du.
Also.
Das ist gleich nebenan.
Das ist nebenan.